in paris every they did this all
without me which is great so i'm going
to go back to paris and see who else
they hire next year
so ben going off the grid thanks mike
all right
no no pressure there right they close
this off all right so what do i want to
talk about today so i i guess i i
hopefully will be light because i'm sure
everybody's brain is far too full uh
i'll be referencing back to a lot of
things that have come before um
i kind of just want to go off on some
some some new directions that i've been
looking at with uh
as was on the previous slide here my
postdoc gong tang who is here uh and a
grad student who recently graduated
audrey baskara and other postdoc parisha
um
just on some ideas of kind of extending
some of the things that i think we're
very we know well and we know when we
love things like l1 to kind of
continuous spaces
because
you know we live in a very continuous
world and i think we have classical
signal processing algorithms kind of
deal with things that you know models of
reality that would uh exist in real
numbers but oftentimes when we try to
come up with nice succinct
representations what we end up with is
uh
think this picture which i stole from
rich nick this picture appears in every
talk that richberian gives unfortunately
he wasn't here this week to mock up
about this so we always try to make
things into a nice gridded linear
algebra problem and the quite the
question is always uh in everything and
this has been a question in pdes for
since since they started using computers
is just what's the price for
discretization what's the price for
going off the grid so i'm going to look
today just at the very particular case
of l1 something that i think now we we
know and love and we feel is respected
and the question is what actually
happens when we take our l1 problem
and we try to put it back up
back
off the grid right what happens when we
try to work with continuous parameters
and still do l1
so
the motivating example that i'm going to
use throughout i'm hoping that we can
make this more general later but i'm
just going to motivate with a very
simple one which is just a sum of
complex sinusoids it's like kind of a
really really simple single model so
here we have our kind of standard
sum a very sparse sum so k hopefully
here is going to be small
of complex exponentials and we're going
to assume that the frequencies
are not known to us nor are we going to
and the c's are also not going to be
known and we'd like to estimate them
both simultaneously and they're both
going to be real valued actually the c's
will be complex valued the f's will be
maybe let's say normalized and 0 1.
okay kind of very standard kind of
almost classical signal processing
problem this appears all over the place
obviously will come up in spectroscopy
and it's used in
direction of rival estimation a variety
of sampling theory
but you know with small tweaks we can
actually see this all over the place so
for example if we look at uh
things like ultrasound and seismology
there we're going to have time delays
that don't necessarily lie in the grid
it's kind of like the counterpart now in
the the time domain rather than the
frequency domain
um and then sometimes if we're using
something like gps we're actually going
to have to deal with both we'll deal
with time and frequency and delay and
doppler
in imaging we also have a similar kind
of thing where now we're going to have a
spike train of sources that live
somewhere maybe and then they're going
to be involved with what's called a
point spread function due to imaging
characteristics so
some kind of rayleigh imaging is
actually going to blur out these deltas
and again the goal is to actually
localize where are the actual uh uh
where the stars in the sky where are the
fluorescence on my carbon nanotubes in
that other picture
and if i take the fourier transform this
looks like the problem i started with
again it's a sum of complex sinusoids
again with frequencies that i don't know
so here's i guess the the formulation
this is the spectrum estimation problem
uh the goal is to find a combination of
sinusoids agreeing with some time series
data where the frequency lies in zero
one
and it's not on the grid
okay so how would you do this
i was asking you guys it turns out the
the oldest the earliest example i know
to solve this is due to proney and it
goes back to 1790 or 1795 or something
like this the dawn of time and uh
prone's method is is really beautiful
just uses uh the theory of polynomials
so let me give you a contemporary
version of pronounced method rather than
than his method which sometimes looks
confusing
so
if we make the simplifying assumption
that the coefficients are all
non-negative
these c's are non-negative which
basically means that everything is in
phase
then we can write the following sum
which is the coefficient c times this
complex sinusoid i'm just going to stack
up the time the time samples of one of
the sinusoids and i'm going to multiply
by the adjoint
okay so each of those terms is a
positive definite matrix that sum if the
coefficients are positive is also a
positive definite matrix that's very
convenient
and also it has a very nice structure
which you can work out for yourself uh
it's topless
basically because of the properties that
complex exponential you're going to have
constant enough diagonals in that matrix
and obviously a constant diagonal
this is a topless matrix and pronise
technique basically says if you take
anything in the null space
of this matrix so obviously i only had
three here because i was abbreviating
you imagine that you have much more time
samples so this is like an n by n matrix
where n is bigger than let's say twice k
which would be a very that's actually
what you need
you need n to be twice k
then then as long as this is you take a
vector in the null space that vector you
can think about it as being a polynomial
the coefficients of a polynomial and
that polynomial is going to vanish
exactly exactly at these uk's
this is very interesting so the cloud of
this way about it doing um
polynomial interpolation gives you kind
of a nice solution and this is kind of
the basis of most modern single
processing techniques or the ones that
are commonly taught in early dsp classes
so there are a bunch of
music and esprit and cadzo and there are
a bunch of these other related terms
okay so that's that's that's kind of the
classic way to do it it doesn't
necessarily look like compressed sensing
but uh unfortunately a manual had to
leave but emanuel could say that for the
first year or two that he gave
compressed sensing talks people would
just tell him doshi you know pernice
method you know the interesting thing
about prone's method is as i said we
know in compressed sensing right if you
have s you have a
sparse vector that's sparse you need s
log n or something right you'll see that
come up again
s log n measurements to recover the
sparse vector here you need 2s
so what's it hiding here well it turns
out that this is not very robust as you
might imagine the null space changes a
lot if there's any noise in these
coefficients
and it's actually a very
very non-robust method there's been lots
of work almost all of the work in
array processing goes to making this
robust
so here's our contemporary viewpoint
here's the compressed sensing viewpoint
we're going to write x as f times c
okay where where c is some sparse set of
coefficients we already knew that
and f is let's say a just a the fourier
transform or some partial
uh
partial set of rows of the fourier
transform
okay so this is now we introduce a grid
which is this capital n
but other than that this is kind of so
and that's why you have to make a
squiggle that is approximate so we have
some kind of gridding precision and then
we have this and then what will we do
now that i know that x is basically a
sparse vector
i know it's thursday but you guys know
what would you do
david what would you do
oh l1 magic yeah you saw it with the
lasso right of course what else are we
going to do
there's nothing else to do we just run
the lasso we minimize that that function
sub plus plus mu times the norm of c sub
one um we get out some answer but of
course now we we know that we're on a
grid so now the question is the original
frequencies the uk's weren't
necessarily on that grid
um so we really don't have any
guarantees about what we're going to get
out so those are you have these two
conflicting kind of approaches you have
this classic approach based on
polynomial interpolation uh more
commonly based on the svd um
which is grid free
yeah this other approach which is kind
of we have all this great theory for now
it's robust we have great algorithms uh
we have a lot of great theory um but
there are downsides obviously to both of
these methods the first one is the svd
methods
you need you really need to know how
many sinusoids you're looking for to
make these things work this is kind of a
common practice they're they're slightly
unstable i get into fights with
reviewers about how unstable they are
but we have plots we'll show you these
plots later uh and all the theory about
the svd methods ends up being something
like they saturate the cream or outbound
asymptotically that's about the extent
of there's you can get a little bit more
precise than that but they're all kind
of asymptotic results
on the other hand the l1 method has this
problem that you have a grid this is not
a gridded problem
so the question is just how how should
we bridge this gap
how can we bridge this gap
and that's what we're going to talk
about for the for the remainder today
okay
so it's kind of like the almost like the
classic the first compressed sensing
problem because it's from 1790
so we want to kind of hope to maybe
using what we now know about compressed
sensing let's say some things about this
problem
okay
really straightforward so there's our
setup so what are we going to do what
method are we going to bring to the
table
to do that i want to go back to kind of
something a little bit uh
trying to get off the grid directly in
this kind of problem
i have a matrix equation y equals 5
times x
i know that uh the number of rows of phi
is less than the number of columns
and i would just like to find x so i
have just an over determined system the
question is which actually you pick
uh and you have an infinite set of
solutions and now the question is just
which one do you pick
so
i think venkat talked about this
yesterday uh francis talked about a very
complementary approach just two minutes
ago so we have kind of two different
ways of looking at the same problem the
idea is always you leverage something
that you know right you either leverage
the fact that this thing is there's
either rank or sparsity or smoothness or
some other kind of property of this
signal
and so the general question is how would
i actu if i knew this in advance
how would i design an algorithm to solve
this problem where it goes as follows i
give you a linear equation i give you
some kind of prior about the solution
and then i want to solve it yes han
let's just let's just be simple say one
single signal
yes as an infinite dictionary
yes exactly
that's the setup so now i'm going to
actually return to something i'm going
to start with something maybe a little
bit simpler but also more general and
then use that to actually apply it back
to our basically what i want to get to
the heart of is this
we kind of have a general procedure now
to solve this kind of problem how when i
say it's a very rhetorical question
obviously we kind of know as a community
how to do it and i'm just going to walk
us through what we always do
no so the fourier transformation does
actually not give you back the
frequencies when you do a finite fourier
transform you do not get the frequencies
back you're always you're actually uh
in the limit that you take an infinite
number of samples then you get them back
but pro knee takes two s samples so i
have i have a sine wave
i uh i take the first two s samples and
then i'm able to actually uh you know
sorry i have a sum of s sine waves i
take the first two samples i can
actually recover the coefficients
and the frequencies exactly i don't have
to go to infinity
so that's the question is what how does
that work and how can we actually kind
of understand that in our framework does
that make sense okay so the question is
just like it's not you can't just take
the fourier transform it's a little bit
hard to see that but if i have a very
short number of samples it's not you're
going to get a very noisy signal back
um
but
okay
all right
so let's go back to let's go to this
general thing and i just kind of want to
walk through what we kind of always do
so what we always do it always ends up
looking well not always but more or less
a lot of things kind of reduced to this
you identify the simple model
which are these the red dots on the
corner of this uh here this is our
sparse vectors
so if i color in these sparse vectors i
get the l1 ball
i color in the convex hull of the sparse
vectors i get the l1 ball
and what does it mean to minimize the l1
norm subject to linear quality
constraints it means blow up the l1 ball
until it hits
the equality constraints
okay that is that definition of that
problem i stole this picture very
shamelessly from a paper by uh candace
romberg and tao
basically motivating the use of this
heuristic
and the idea is that if i have a sparse
solution or if i have a solution i care
about it's going to lie very far out in
the convex hull and the convex hole is
going to be very pointy where i care
about so i blow up this ball and i'm
going to hit one of these corners
that's the intuition and that's actually
the theory that you go and use
so here's here's another example rank
we've been hearing things about matrix
rank
here are two by two matrices that are
rank one they are these red circles
again with norm one you color in there
convex hall this ends up being the
nuclear norm
the nuclear norm is the basis of many
different heuristics for solving um
for solving problems involving low rank
matrices
this is just the sum of the singular
values of the matrix and again the
picture looks the same the pointy parts
the extreme parts are the convex hall
and you know this is kind of the basis
between behind uh
mariam fossils thesis
uh and and also my work with mariam and
palo parillo on understanding how
why this heuristic has been so
successful for so long at uh at finding
low rank matrices it kind of led to
matrix completion a variety of other
fields okay so all right so there's
another one
you can do it for let's say integer
programming
to be another case and this is kind of
like the the uh for my computer science
friends in the room this would be the
the simplest thing that you would try
and then it will immediately not work
but that's okay well let's just try it
we have a problem that involves integer
solutions we try to just maximize
minimize the convex whole norm which
turns out here to be the infinity norm
and then sometimes you get a solution we
can actually characterize when that
works as well it's the same picture it
turns out it doesn't work that well you
basically need this problem to be
incredibly over determined you
essentially need
if you have a binary vector in rn
then you need n over two linear
measurements to define it so it's not
necessarily useful for for heuristics
but it's kind of interesting that you
can have a very similar analysis
okay so so there were three and i could
keep going i might tell you a few more
obviously we're going to have to get to
how we do the same idea for these kind
of complex sinusoids but let's just
start here so we have this model that
we'd like to fit we have some atoms that
we know i've told you in advance these
are the basic building blocks we want to
fit some kind of sparse combination of
these basic building blocks and we
always do the same thing we blow up the
convex hull until it hits the alpine
space and you could define that as
minimizing the sum of the absolute value
of the coefficients subject to this
decomposition holding
it's always what it is
so it looks like the l1 norm
but the set of coefficient these alphas
that you're choosing there's you could
have an infinite collection of alphas
the set of rank one matrices is infinite
the set of complex sinusoids is infinite
and so you get a different pro you get a
different
uh problem out depending on
uh
uh how you pick these atoms
okay
so we we call these things atomic norms
uh just because
we couldn't find a clean name for them
in in the literature because they're
very spec and it was kind of funny after
the nuclear norm to go do atomic worms
tell that joke too many times
but the idea here is exactly what i said
at the beginning you you you have you
take your convex hull you blow it up
until you hit x
and it turns out under very mild
conditions that's exactly what i said on
the previous slide is the sum of the
coefficients subject to the
decomposition holding it's the smallest
sum of absolute coefficients subject to
the decomposition holding
and so it kind of gives us an idea this
is when i said how do we design an
algorithm this at least gives us an
optimization problem the optimization
problem is minimizing the atomic norm
subject to my data holding true
okay and and so that's kind of a meta
algorithm
the nice thing is that this atomic norm
is always convex by construction it's
always convex it's not necessarily
always solvable however we want to know
under what cases is it solvable and
efficiently and how we actually go about
doing that
okay
so we have a kind of meta approach to
solving these kind of uh
complexity constrained problems
so so in some work with venkat chandra
sacram who unfortunately had to catch a
flight so i can't say nice things maybe
i should stop saying nice things about
him didn't get a chance to see him this
afternoon um and and with paulo parrillo
and alan wilson we kind of we wrote a
nice uh uh a paper just kind of
detailing how this works in general kind
of gives you a one way it says when can
you solve it it kind of gives you a few
different algorithms for how you might
solve it uh it gives you nice ways to
get complexity results which i'll talk
to you about in a second um
and i guess what's kind of what's kind
of cute they give you one it gives you a
general idea it gives you a starting
point for something to try when you
bring a prior to the table
so oftentimes i think the the this is
not the prior necessarily in kind of a
probabilistic sense this is more of a
kind of structural sense it gives you
something to try and something to
analyze
so some examples of things that you can
kind of use in this framework uh so
francis talked a little bit about block
sparsity you could do these kind of
group sparsity in a very similar setup
if you use submodularity you get a
slightly different norm than if you use
this atomic norms but you know who's
checking they're basically the same
thing and uh and and in this case again
you have an infinite dictionary because
you're looking at these kind of more
complex subspaces
uh for for for ranking things and for
permutations you can also define this
very similarly if you take the convex
hull of the permutations you get the
doubly stochastic matrices and so now it
basically kind of motivates this this
gives you a framework to understand when
does that doubly stochastic relaxation
uh work to recover permutations
and there are other examples we're going
to focus a lot on that top one which is
the idea of moments actually just the
idea of complex sinusoids but there are
also
you could do cut matrices in that case
actually you cannot solve the problem
but it can be approximated using
semi-definite programming and you can
you can determine how well it does via
growth in the extended quality you can
even think about tensors in this
framework as well and give you kind of a
way forward towards the heuristic for
dealing with tensors okay so lots of
things we can solve and and what's nice
is that actually you kind of it also
gives you one way to prove things which
is actually how we're going to prove
things about moments i just want to
spend a second because this i said this
at the boot camp and i'm going to say it
again there's basically only one thing
you do the nice thing when you do convex
uh
when you when you make the problem
convex it makes
what you prove very clear and that's the
following if i want to show that x is
the thing that has the smallest norm
subject to equality constraints
i just look at all the directions that
make the norm smaller i look at all the
directions that stay feasible
and then i just prove that they
intersect at zero
so it kind of gives you one way to you
know it tells you what you exactly have
to show every time and pretty much every
result in compressed sensing and matrix
completion and a variety of these other
kind of structures sparsities reduces to
this you prove this in in a variety of
different ways so
that's that's
if only it was that easy but in the case
of uh what uh in the paper with with
venkat we actually analyze uh the case
of gaussian matrices and it is actually
it reduces to just computing the
gaussian complexity of this set of
direct directions but you know in
general this is what you have to do and
this is what we're going to aim to do
here
okay but just uh
well i always show this slide but not
necessarily the other nice thing about
this framework is it actually for for
problems that we knew the answer to
already it kind of gave us really nice
bounce on the number of measurements
required to recover simple models
so it tells you basically we know that
for the hypercube if you have uh in this
case
i've given many variants of this talk
clearly this talk was taken from a talk
i gave in statistics you can tell the by
the notation here because what is that p
doing there p is the number of
parameters n is the number of
measurements so you need for the
hypercube if you have a p-dimensional
vector you need uh the number of
measurements should be half p
for sparse vectors you need 2s log p
over s and this is actually giving you a
non-asymptotic
proof of a result known by a donahoe and
tanner
you can get results for block sparsity
you get a very nice result for matrices
this number on this side is basically
the number of numbers required to write
down the singular value decomposition
and you only need a factor of three more
to recover it from uh kind of random
measurements so it's kind of it it gives
you basically the results you expect and
gives you very tight bounce on on on on
estimating how many measurements you
need in a variety of these different
problems so this is kind of another
reason why we really like this framework
we could also do something like with
robust recovery i'm going to skip this
slide and we can also do a statistical
robust recovery it's too late in the day
to go through that one those two are too
dense anyway but you could also get
statistical rates let's just say it this
way if you were to solve something like
the lasso we can again get things that
you kind of know to be true you get
things like that if i have a
low rank matrix then the number of
measurements i'm going to need is r
divided by the number of parameters uh
if you if you have a sparse vector
that's going to be s log p over p so
it's kind of it's what you expect it to
get
so that's the nice thing we kind of have
a way to do this statistically we have a
way to do this deterministically we kind
of can recover a lot of results we know
but here's a question can we prove
things we didn't know yet
how do we prove things we didn't know
and that for that we're going to return
to our fun problem spectrum estimation
so for this we could be a lot more
specific we could talk about exactly
what comes out of this framework okay so
in spectrum estimation again sparse
combination of
sinusoids what are the atoms these are
the atoms
so basically what i'm going to assume
i'm actually assuming a very simple
model here home which makes it very
confusing i'm assuming that the ph
matrix is the identity
right now the fee matrix is the identity
so you just see the vector
and we just want to say does the atomic
norm return the decomposition that's the
first question we'll ask
so the atomic norm what we're going to
do is we're just going to write down
uh the components of a single sinusoid
with no coefficient
a face
this is one sinusoid with a face the
phase and the and the frequency are real
and if you take complex combinations of
these you get
you get samples like we have up here
and classical techniques like i said
like the all of the ones that you learn
in signal processing if you take the
first year grad class
basically use this topless thing they
use this topless matrix being positive
definite and the properties of the null
space of that matrix to prove all of
their results
so we're going to follow that lead it
turns out
that if i wanted to do this problem
which is minimize my my my norm subject
to some data
what am i going to do i have my atomic
set the question is how do we actually
solve this
and how do we you know how can we
actually
uh find or approximate the signal from
from from partial measurements and from
noisy measurements
all right
so here's how it works again remember
this slide i i showed you to you at the
beginning so hopefully this is probably
the most important one in the whole talk
just something to remember what you the
trick is always you take your you take
your vector of sinusoids you multiply by
its adjoint that's positive definite
i sum up
the i take ck i multiply that in and i
sum them up and i get a positive
definite topless matrices
it turns out that the convex hull
of the atoms in the case you have
positive positive coefficients that
means that their in phase is exactly the
set of positive definite topless
matrices
and when you have phase you basically
just have to add an extra dilation it's
a little more complicated and i can't i
don't really
it's definitely too late in the day to
go through the details to prove this but
it's very not hard to say that the the
norm of the general one where the cks
are general are you put x on the border
of the topless matrix you just try to
complete this matrix you want to find a
topless completion of this matrix that's
positive definite
such that the diagonal of the topless
matrix plus this upper
coefficient t
the sum is as small as possible
it's very it's a little bit of a
confusing looking expression but that's
basically what so basically we're taking
into account a phase by basically
bordering the topless matrix with x
okay and what you can actually show is
that the null space of this topless
matrix corresponds exactly to
uh to a polynomial that vanishes at the
uks just like in prone's technique but
we turned out we don't need to actually
use that anymore when we solve our
problem we have another way of actually
recovering these frequencies okay
and so this is what one of the compact
cells looked like this is our funny
picture it says it's a very beautiful
object this is called the moment curve
and this is actually the moment hull the
black line on the outside is the moment
curve
uh and the coefficients here lie on the
circle so here's here's that picture
again this is a curve where we're just
tracing out cosine
of t cosine of 2t cosine of 3t
and then if you kind of draw in the
convex hole you get this object
this object has a lot of nice
compact properties in particular if you
take a gridding of that
and then you connect the lines every
every line here
every line between two points forms a
face
it forms an edge it's called neighborly
in this in this definition
unfortunately when we actually add phase
like we have in real life so you
actually are allowed to have sinusoids
that appear out of phase which often
happens in spectroscopy it happens in
direction of arrival the object gets a
lot more complicated you actually need a
lot more measurements to decode things
that have face then that don't but that
shouldn't be particularly surprising for
folks who've played with sinusoids
before because you can do things like
the
destructive
interference
so basically if i take two sinusoids and
i add them i'm still going to have a
very big signal
but if i take two sinusoids and the
frequencies are close and i subtract
them i can have this thing vanish
and there's um
there's even crazier things you can do
there's a great example in a paper by
emmanuel candes and carlos fernandez
ground up where you basically can have a
1024 samples
you'll have a frequency a signal that
has basically 48 sinusoids
the
coefficients all sum to one and then
what you observe has a norm 10 to the
minus 70.
so basically you can get
the more sinusoids you add the nastier
this deconstruct this destructive
interference gets
and so that's kind of why this problem
is actually much harder when you have a
face
and when you have
realistic settings
okay so so let me add one more thing
i've been showing you this slide over
and over we have to add one more thing
in order to avoid this kind of
catastrophic uh interference what we're
going to do is assume that these these
the frequencies and our bases are far
apart
essentially we're kind of assuming a
resolution a
like a rayleigh limit for the problem
we're assuming that we have a little bit
of separation i'm still not assuming
they're on the grid they can be anywhere
you want they just have to be far apart
from each other
and then we're going to solve
our atomic norm lasso-like problem
because this is what we do we just
replace the l1 with this atomic norm
so what can we actually prove about this
we can prove that the mean square error
goes like goes as follows it goes as s
the number of coefficients
log n over n where that's the
observation time
so the mean square error goes to zero if
you have an infinite observation time
which we would hope so that works for
the fourier transform as well but here
we actually have a very quantitative
bound and a finite regime
and uh moreover that this is minimax
optimal
almost up to n over s but who's counting
the extra log amongst friends today so
at the end of the day basically no
algorithm can ever do better than s log
n over s over n
so essentially the atomic norm is giving
us kind of the um as good as we can
expect to do even when these frequencies
we assume this well separation
and certainly no algorithm could ever do
better than sigma squared s over n
even if i told you where all the
frequencies were right because in that
case it's just linear regression and
this is
just to come up with the coefficients
you couldn't do better than that so it's
actually so it does surprisingly well
very well and and
now we're just kind of go have to fight
over the constant
um we could either fire over the
constant
or you know we get these reviews we get
reviews back that say that
uh but but music saturates the kramer
outbound so we have to actually now look
at mean square error
you could
actually it's not enough to just say but
creamer outbound assumes that the
estimator is unbiased you can't do that
in signal processing my statistics
friends
so what we did was we actually compared
to some classical algorithms
and in terms of mean square error this
actually does surprisingly well you
solve this problem you solve the
semi-definite programming problem and in
terms of just the mean square error of
the rest reconstructed signal this is
kind of like a denoising problem
we do quite well we we are kind of at
um
looks like our lines are below the the
lines of the competitive algorithms
which is always where you want to be
um the thing that i find very
interesting is for this particular
problem of just recovering the signal
not necessarily recovering the
frequencies the lasso is also quite good
so this is a lasso where we just do this
gridding thing we actually stay on the
grid and so for the purpose of
prediction the lasso is perfectly good
but if there's if you actually care
about the frequencies you might be out
of luck so we have to talk about the
thing maybe that we care about which is
finding these frequencies
okay so
this slide is messy i unfortunately i
wish i had a better way gongo is going
to help me make this slide better
because i hate giving this describing
what's in here but this is for the
people who care what we really care
about localizing the frequencies not
just recovering the signal
and so we have a picture here of
basically
uh kind of a frequency plot that you
might see in a paper where you're
looking at music where you're sweeping
through all the frequencies
uh the green ones are the true frequency
and then we have a couple different
regions that we might look at we might
say how many frequencies do you find
that lie far away when i do spectroscopy
how many spurious signals am i going to
do from spectroscopy and we can prove
that that goes to zero
uh using in this model
uh
and yeah we borrowed that actually we
should blame carlos for
we we borrowed these definitions and
kind of did this kind of
characterization of frequency
localization from carlos so this is
something that he can look we could also
say basically how well do we approximate
the mass when we're near the true
frequency and that also goes to zero we
also say how well do we actually see
that the coefficients roll off uh when
we wait as their distance to the true
frequency and that also goes to zero so
we have three characterizations of how
well we're localization all of them are
going to zero
and all of them are going to zero at
what we think is an almost optimal rate
the lasso if you actually lie on a grid
would basically get the same results
except there would be no k here so
that's the one thing that we haven't
figured out how to clean up but
hopefully we can get rid of that bound
too
and again i could bore you but let's not
do too much yeah we this is also better
than this is actually the thing i think
striking we get better localization than
the existing methods and i think that
that's the part where uh i
i'm excited that it works but i'm not
surprised because this is where the root
finding that kind of comes into these
classical methods really can go ori the
polynomial interpolation is very
insensitive it's very sensitive to noise
and our method doesn't actually use that
polynomial interpolation
uh depending on how you want to look at
this these are these are what the s and
r plots okay sorry these are performance
profiles so here's our sr plus again we
lie below this
so we're able to
localize the frequencies under the
presence of noise
again this and we're able to
reconstruct the signal we're able to
denoise so now i want to talk about that
last thing which is now what would be
our linear operator that we might be
interested in applying what how do we
bring in now can we uh estimate the
signal under missing data
under partial information
and so this would be where we get to the
the notion of compressed sensing
so we have a very particular notion of
compressed sensing uh
uh
i know that i thought the author was in
the room there's there's a there's a
paper by some folks in michigan that
look at a different model for compressed
sensing uh when you're with
non-grid-based frequencies but this
we're here we're kind of modeling a very
particular model that was introduced by
candace romberg and tao so this is the
following it's basically saying that i
could take time samples and then ignore
a bunch of them
so you want to say that if what if i
were only to require time samples on
this kind of sparsely sampled grid
okay this is the kind of compressed
sensing model this was kind of when when
the word compressed sensing was invented
this was kind of what we meant so it
would be basically let's just take a
random subset of samples from zero to n
minus one we'll take a ram subset of
some size and then say when can we
actually how many random samples do we
need to actually recover the signal
exactly
this is the heart of what we mean in
compressed sensing but what i would like
to what we'd like to say here is now
let's not restrict the frequencies to
line of grid
let's actually be off of a grid so what
we're going to do is again now we have a
linear constraint we have a measurement
model we're going to try to localize
these frequencies under that model and
we have a method using semi-definite
programming to extract the frequencies
and the coefficients
and so basically
um our proof is the the analysis here is
inspired by a result by the the original
paper by candice and fernandez granda on
this topic
they used a different norm in this
setting but it turns out that these two
things end up being equivalent they use
something called a total variation norm
we use something called we use the
atomic norm they turn out to be
equivalent norms
but what essentially was proven in the
first paper was that if we assume that
the signals are separated
and we take 2s samples which is kind of
what proney's setting and we have no
noise then l1 works too provided that
you have separation
now in some sense this is a bit of a
negative result because actually l1
requires this if you don't have good
separation you can actually l1 doesn't
work
so kind of this atomic norm does not
work in the case that you don't have
good separation
but pro knee works even though prone is
very insensitive and very noise
sensitive
um so in some senses so almost the
negative result however the the proof
techniques which again are we have a
subspace we have a set of directions
that make uh make our functions smaller
we want to prove that they intersect at
zero the proof techniques extend to a
lot of exciting results so there are uh
a bunch of follow-up papers just
basically kind of building on the the
structure of this proof showing that
it's actually robust
showing that also that we can now
recover things from partial information
and so this is our theorem it says that
if we take a longer observation time
but very few samples so just s times log
s over log n s times log s times log n
and i don't know if you actually need
this log s but it just comes out in our
calculation
then you can again now we recover things
with separation four over n
so longer observation time lets you
resolve
signals that are closer together
frequencies that are closer together
and this is kind of at the heart of what
why people are interested in compressed
sensing to begin with if you take
uniform samples
and you actually do these experiments
you take one of these phantoms that you
see in the first compressed sensing
paper you take equispace samples you get
a very crude image when you try to do
reconstruction however if you just
jitter them a little bit and so you make
them so they're on a grid of size n
rather than s
you get a great reconstruction and so we
actually now
on the grid this is really just what's
in the original compressed sensing paper
but off the grid this is new
and it's very very neat that you can
actually recover these things
and their real
values um i think the other takeaway
that's interesting because always what
we think in compressed sensing is
somehow that we need some kind of coh
incoherence in order to make things work
you need somehow that your dictionary
elements have dot products that are very
small
here we have an infinite dictionary and
in particular you have
candidate solutions whose dot product is
quite large uh so we don't actually have
coherence but what we do have is that
the true solution
has to have this kind of resolution
condition
essentially the the true solution is uh
the the are pairwise incoherent with
each other
so where are we going with this well
there are lots of other things that we
might want to look at beyond just this
kind of compressed sensing problem in
particular in imaging oftentimes you
really just have a discrete measurement
of a point spread function applied to
some data so we're hoping that we might
be able to extend these techniques to
that method
and i think we're kind of looking a
little bit broader to where else we can
go i think there are lots of different
directions that we can go in terms of
looking at different moment problems
perhaps problems in differential
equations perhaps problems in feature
selection where we can actually really
use these kind of atomic norm techniques
to to
understand how to interface
continuous models
with some of our
with some of our algorithms have been up
to date restricted to being on a grid
all right so that's that's what i've got
for today uh thanks everybody for
sticking out to the end and
let's all have a drink
right
uh not with this model because again
that's where you can have the that's
where you can have this kind of uh uh
destructive interference that's actually
the worst case is when you have two guys
that are right on top of each other and
that's where they're going to cancel
each other out
well that was the we have that example
always uh let's see if i can get to that
quickly i always forget how to do this
maybe on slide 15
too far i usually know where these
things are
this this is the example where you have
two two frequencies that are very close
to each other right and then everywhere
in that everywhere in the observation
time that signal is small
everywhere
everywhere that you might observe it
let's say we have a limited space of
observation time right that's that's
interesting
i think the point is that you're only
allowed to sample on a short observation
window that's a that's really the key
here is that the the short observation
time
is what really makes the problem hard
okay so let's thank them